Mark: Hey guys, how's it going?
Mark: Welcome to the egg roulette challenge. *Matthias hand seizure*.
Mark: a wah wub wah wub
J-Fred: Yeah welcome back. Niger is a country in Africa.
Mark: What is that?
Matt: Oh I'm waving.
Matt: Oh I'm waving with my- sorry bad hand.
Mark: *mumbles sexual joke*
[All laugh]
Mark: Eh eh just a little bit. [laughs]
Mark: We wont put that in
Mark: Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier
and I'm here- why?
[Matt laughs]
Mark: [laughing] Why continue with the joke?
Matt: [laughing] It was like completely different!
Mark: I'm keeping it in now!
Mark: Welcome to the egg roulette challenge
[Matt makes kissy noise]
Mark: I'm here with Team Edge and they're all gonna be joining me on this awesome challenge
Mark: that I've never done before but they have
Mark: So, uh, explain it.
Matt: It's... eggs...
On ya head.
J-Fred: There's some hard boiled eggs, there's some raw eggs.
J-Fred: You don't want the raw eggs on your head because it's wet and gooey.
Mark: [Giddy with the promise of goo] Wet and gooey!
Bryan: There's 8 raw eggs in here.
J-Fred: (correcting Bryan) There's 12 raw eggs in here.
Mark and Bryan: Ohhhh
Bryan: [whispers] 12, oh snap
Mark: I was getting there
J-Fred: Where'd you get 8 from?
Bryan: I thought that's what we talked about, 8.
[Mark chuckles]
J-Fred: You said to put 2 for every 6!
Matt: Alright, alright!
J-Fred: One third. 12 of 36!
[Lots of shouting]
Matt: Okokok enough bickering!
Mark: We're fraaaands!
J-Fred: Daaaaaaaa!!! [slaps table]
Demon J-Fred: Daaaaaaahhhh!!!
Bryan: So once you get hit by 2 raw eggs you're out.
Done.
Mark: Whoooaaaaaap.
Eggs (silently): The claaaaaaaw.
Bryan: Get it!
Mark (quietly): Oh man...
J-Fred: Oh that looks like aaa-
Bryan: That's a raw one!
J-Fred (continuing): raw one!
Mark: How do you know?
J-Fred: I don't know.
Mark (insisting): How do you know!?
J-Fred: I don't.
Bryan: Just smash it on your head!
Mark: HOW DO YOU KNOW!
J-Fred: I don't.
[Mark makes girly squeal]
[Egg splats]
All: OhhhhhhhhhhHHHHH!!! Hahahahaha
[Clapping]
Bryan: Just leave it right there.
Oh! Not on me!
All: Ewwwwwwww!
Bryan: Aaaaaaaaaand-AH...
Bryan (quietly): Oh that's a- that's a raw one.
[Egg splats]
Matt: Yeah!!
[All laugh]
Mark: I'm gonna laugh when they're all raw.
[Bryan groaning]
Matt: Yeah why are they all raw?!
[Mark laughing]
[Bryan groaning still]
J-Fred: Jokes on you!
[Mark chuckling]
Matt: No you're going next, joke's on you!
[Egg cracks]
J-Fred: Yes....
Matt: He knew...
Bryan: He knew, He cheated. Go!
Bryan: Ah. That's it. I think he's good.
Matt: [Girly Scream]
Matt: [Higher pitched Girly Scream]
Mark: Nice!
J-Fred: Noooo!
Bryan: Dang it
Mark: I'm gonna get egg goop all over me
Matt: Oh, OH your seeping dude! (Matt Wut?)
Mark: Thank you man.
Mark: 3 2 1!
Brian: Oh, Lucky.
Mark: WhoooooHoooo
Brian: Alright.
J-Fred: Do- You cant look
Bryan: I wasnt!
Mark: Can I eat it? (No Mark, you cant)
Brian: AYA!
Brian: NOOOOOOOOOOOO!
Matt: YEEEES!
Matt: Wait...
Mark: Wait...
Mark: You're Good!
Brian: Oh its not - Oh okay.
[Mark Laughing]
J-Fred: It's just not cooked very good!
Mark: It was the previous Goop.
Matt: [Loud Girlish Scream]
Matt: [Louder Girlish Scream (Matt you okay bro?)]
Matt: This is upsetting :(
Mark: This is disgusting
J Fred: I mean, I didn't cook them for eating.
Brian: Ugh
Matt: That's not cooked at all
Brian: What?!
J-Fred: Oh, they pulled my hairs... [All chuckle]
Matt: [Yet another high-pitched girlish scream] J-Fred: Why?
J-Fred: He knew he was cheating? Matt: How can I know when I’m not looking? [Laughing]
Mark: [Laughing] No! He’s looking right at me! [All laughing]
Brian: He cheated!
Matt: [Louder whimper, loud high-pitched scream]
[Egg cracks]
Matt, Mark and J-Fred: OHHHHHHH!
Brian: YES!!
J-Fred: You knew which one you were picking.
Mark: You knew! You cheater!
J-Fred: You purposely picked it out
J-Fred: I'm so glad I'm the only one who hasn't gotten it
Matt: Convenient, huh?
Matt: You're the one who boiled them. Mark: Alright, here we go
Mark: 3 2 1 go. J-Fred: You're like so emotional right now.
Brian: Ohhh!
Mark: Yeah!!!
Bryan: Ahh. This is a raw one. Matt: You're out. [Egg cracks]
Mark: Ooooohh
Mark: They're not good.
J-Fred: Ooohh!
- Others: Yeaah!!
Matt: Yes!!
Mark: Alright, now comes the [Mark has a stroke]
Brian: The little bangs over there
[others laughing]
Matt: [high-pitched noise]
Matt: [relieved] Yes
[others groan]
J-Fred: So we all have heen -- "heen" -- been hit by one.
Mark: Ohh, I'm already -- I'm good!
Mark: I already know!
Mark: Yeaaaahhh!!  [laughs]
ah [heavy breathing]
Matt: youre...?
Mark: ahh nice
Bryan: whaat??
Mark: a softy ;)
Mark: its a softy [again]
Matt: eww
[Matt makes vomit noises]
Matt: no that was just a normal burp
[weird chorus of yeahs]
Matt: what are you- whats the matter?
bryan: [amused] its pulling his hair!!
Mark: youre fine... youre fine
bryan: its got [laughs]
Mark: its got you! its got him!
j-fred: alright I'm good
[j-fred does boss egg drop]
Bryan: That's- That's a good one. Uh-Oh. Go! Go! Matt: NOO! -Others: YASS!
-Others: [still cheering] Mark: Was that two? Bryan: That's two!
Matt: DANG IT!
Mark: Oh no. It's a raw one. This is a raw one isn't it!?
Mark: [Screams like a girl]
Others: YASS!
Mark: [Laughs and cries]
Bryan: Stop! J-Fred: You knew which one you want! Matt: Oh yea! Exaclty!
Bryan: That's the one I touched. Ima get me right in the forehead. [Screams]
Matt: Convenient.
Bryan: Pull it. J-Fred: It keeps pulling my hairs out.
[Mark mocking him in awkward baby voice]
Bryan: Here do the honors.
Bryan: No. Mark
[Arguing about who gets to do the honors] (ME: JUST DO IT)
Bryan: YAS!
[Still arguing]
Bryan:YAS!
Bryan: [Groaning in pain voices]
Everyone but Bryan: YASS!
Matt: J-Fred wins!
Mark: Put up a- Me later. Put up a big J-Fred wins. Yay!
J-Fred: Yea! A big one!
Mark: Good job me. Thanks me. Oh your welcome me. I'll give you a hand-job later me. Ahh thanks man.
Matt: [Laughs]
J-Fred: So will I.
Mark: Alright so thank you everybody for watching. If you want to see another challenge we are going to be doing the soda roulette challenge, something similar to this over on Team Edges channel. So check it out in the description below.
Mark: Thanks guys for joining me and as always I will see you in the next one. EWW
Mark: Bye guys! Ewww!
Matt: That's so nasty!